hello and welcome to this video yeah
this is the quest for the lost rating
points did that looks terrible 3 2 3 30
yeah I've lost so many points in the
last live session on Monday I really
played bad bad bad chance there so
trying to get this bag and a plane
tickets was on a very low rating yeah
that's not great very decent GM here
from Hungary and he's yeah he's got no
rating basically for his standards but
should be too hmm usually you can do
this for Nia is that possible here
deform was that not good I don't know I
thought that this is good photo ID had
to go do for but anyway I might be wrong
okay so if i play b5 now takes takes 94
wins wins material so that's not good I
was thinking here and hope to make this
night look bad on a four that was my
idea we'll see what happens yeah so he
wants to go Knight to e5 and trade this
yeah i would like to go Knight to d7 but
t4 is hanging unfortunately well how to
do that 98 is a common idea but then 95
who don't like that too much anyway
spending too much time here hmm ok wants
to go not be 64 ok I'm still happy that
I can support the center with e 5 and
not having trade things I think 95 was
stronger not totally sure but it is
rather complicated ok he wants to play
before here maybe I go here first so e5
there was before with queen bee three
tricks might still be possible before
but that movie em I think is useful in
most cases it runs it two nite h4 queen
age five dollars this could be something
I had exactly the same thing in earlier
game and then somewhat took see a dandy
6 was dropping mm-hmm doing that
surprising I think that's the eighth was
strong
now this this is not so dangerous i
think and i would love to preserve that
bishop I really would like to do that to
have the light square I won't be should
be six here but i have no good square i
can actually go here yeah probably
should age 52 f seven
no looks a little bit loose that Bishop
is unprotected but I see no tactic at
the mode you can go before but I think
I'll take and play Bishop age 52 f 7
this is this is ok but my knight doesn't
have squares right
Oh case can go to a 4 p-5 Bishop f7
Queen a for Bishop takes you five it
might just work em shaky business ok
Bishop back and see playing hmm I don't
know may I play Bishop to g5 but that
doesn't look dangerous I think ok I
probably have to take yeah there's those
trades those traits helped the white a
little bit relate they really did help
him hmm ok how can i activate this
position here b5 is amazingly annoying I
can just go 9 27 and to trade I can and
I'm too slow here I be five I take
stakes be 5 9 a-5 Queen a form no we're
sticking that ok I never expect to move
him
now I get a night to d5 which is not
badly placed now I don't think that this
was so great hey I it still still learn
some still very tricky here yeah this is
what i was thinking yes to do something
something drastic otherwise he he drifts
into a bad position okay mmm 96 it's not
good yeah I've click f4 he will check
before I guess the thing is with the
queen is the annoying annoying way but
ok I can actually play nine to six maybe
this is not so bad now some some things
hanging now
okay g5 I cannot play what I can't i'm
one can do this and grab the form
55 seconds I'm not a porn up hmm who are
somehow thinking I'm the porn hub which
I'm not funny 96 something
okay no man that wasn't good yeah that
isn't great really isn't they've got no
time
Jeff 19 seconds check okay time-wise I'm
somewhere okay now check check check
check musician is a draw i think check
objectively at least
what is he doing now white foreheads
time wow I was very lucky at some
connection you thing well I think it's I
think it's probably a draw I think it's
a draw maybe he has some way to
outmaneuver me hear it yeah you know i'm
not quite sure oh yeah okay i was a
tough game was a tough game here this is
benoni I think what was what I was
surprised that he didn't just take on c8
I think this is just good ok maybe he's
got hmm ok I was thinking I have to do
this but then night cheeks and tme I'm
getting c5 if he takes here I can take
care and of course he's better him fired
she had some tough business yeah maybe
97 was stronger here instead of this I
wasn't sure about this move take here
and now Queenie for but I can take here
okay that's that's what I didn't see and
it's probably not see several is
probably better than okay here engine
gives this movable just and stunning me
a little bit
what this is the engine light if someone
plays it against you you know that
they're cheating this is hanging on h5
and if i if i remove it then it takes
here rook takes Bishop takes takes on
yourself this clothesline that's
completely inhuman nobody does that yeah
this is the kind of tactic that not even
a world championship level player would
find impossible it's just too too weird
I think it's very unlikely again anyway
night age for in Tierra I mean some some
kind of trouble here it's night days is
very annoying that surprised me and the
engine also doesn't like it wants to
play Knight b6 then be five yeah his
pawns in a dangerous this is the thing
this is a very bad piece but the points
here are very dangerous so I think white
is better here and somehow now I f4 it's
very important if he doesn't play that I
think I'm getting control of this
position rather quickly yeah like night
here queen d 7 mmm consolidating but
f-for is a strong move yeah I think I
have to take now we have this this
situation okay I'm pull down I don't
quite get how I lost upon I am losing d4
here this is the thing I lost before I
didn't even write register that okay
this happened and now be six is better
than 25 I guess what okay i was i was
low on time
yeah I think here it should be rather
equal I don't think I should lose this
or get to a lost position but I lost the
thread here yeah yeah it's already
pretty bad it was time and he gets there
I think I'm actually quite happy with
with my defense ya that they think it
was rather rather tough defense well
okay here that's probably losing somehow
but i'm not sure about yeah and this is
also an option this is a pretty good
rook endgame here yeah that looks lost I
think difficult him check oops i had
roped ga ga check that was a draw action
I mean a clean draw okay yeah a tough
game I was very lucky that she had this
connection issue and I basically lost on
time for gab for no reason okay well
thanks for watching